oh God yes that's the ticket that is the
stuff that is the stuff how you feeling
I feel energized B12 up focused full of
life and ready for another 10 to 12 hour
day quenched and fueled is what we feel
here with G fuel they are uh literally
how we survive uh these long days of
having bright lights and cameras and
attention and faces and focus on us OG
fuel so much love one of the best ways
to support the channel is by getting
yourself some g-fill using our special
promo code I want to keep this
partnership forever
to channel out more than any other brand
deal we ever had in our lives because
frankly trailers at 6 a.m Show's
dropping at midnight it's a 24-hour
situation also another thing that helps
out the channel is leaving a like on
this video yes yes so we know that you
like this video and that helps us know
what you want us to watch in this video
or are we watching we're watching
RoboCop too oh my God because people
recommended it very specifically because
we said we would not watch it now we're
here watching we with the entire video
going like I want to preserve this
experience and then all the comments
were like no no I'm I've never seen even
a moving frame I have no clue what this
one's about I knew they rebooted it I
knew that at some point he left Peter
Weller and now I'm about to find out he
is in this one and why and how and if
you want to watch this full experience
please check out the patreon where these
super sexy rejects get to watch this
front back beginning to end with no cuts
to Full Experience you can see our
resting watching faces
as we RoboCop so check it out over there
and also over there Greg and John watch
several other shows exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included without further ado
let's RoboCop too
[Music]
okay yeah this is a different movie you
can already tell I'm so in the little
little drums Kevin Bacon hair
[Music]
looks like a PSA
whoa what is happening oh yes
[Laughter]
no way
no need to trouble the police
it is a PSA it's a commercial it's a
commercial
and it won't even run down your battery
thanks John Glover
[Music]
I love this the Surgeon General is dead
gunned down 20 minutes ago by militant
addict of the deadly designer drug nuke
the greatest Health threat facing our
nation oh we're going to deal with drugs
this time oh early 90s the most
addictive narcotic in history
a plague
wow the news does not censor here nope
not Frank Miller's Universe people want
paradise and they will have it the
assassination is the latest Act of
terrorism by Kane following the
firebombing of a drug treatment Clinic
terrorists or misunderstood just wants
Paradise
what are you gonna do ocp cut out
salaries 40 and cancel our pensions God
knows why but they want this straight
okay so they haven't dropped the
commentary no not at all so far
what happened
wow
[Music]
Detroit's not great that Homeless lady
was walking around with all that [__]
she just mugged another lady
real Circle of Life situation I hope
this movie is just
whatever's been stolen just keeps
getting passed away
[Music]
all right come on come on
this definitely reminds me of Dark
Knight Returns like we'd like to talk
about the TV last time but also the bad
guy talking to the camera and like
planning his stuff and how bad Gotham's
got oh sure sure where's the Bulls
this one's definitely a lot more cheesy
immediately
[Music]
hey this guy always played this kind of
role yeah this guy's like the face of
this
it is an interesting time to set it
where cops are on strike so there could
be like it's like The Purge getting us
in the streets or something the first
movie had that at the end where it was
threatened remember I think they set it
up
[Music]
was there anyone in that car and did not
see a driver there non-descript villain
of the 80s and 90s
he's gone
well they got set pieces down
[Music]
shot through the flickering
oh when humans are on strike machines
will do the jobs
did you slim down buddy you got a little
leaner
moving great
peace officer
[Music]
take it over creep
he's a little brighter in per player
Luke
where is it made it's not mine man I
told you I'm clean
[Music]
the music with that walk is a choice
Peter Weller did not return for a third
RoboCop
it's like a Schumacher world now oh yeah
I could call
all right
we've never opened credits yet right
this feels like the 90s oh yeah it's
weird this one feels dated versus the
last one which was the 80s but didn't
feel they didn't yeah it feels like
super specifically 90s who directed this
uh I heard Irvin kirschner is director
of Empire Strikes Back director to this
yeah all right
even that live Terminator soundtrack
nice speaking of Terminator
instead of the reach through just the
one punch
what a silly shot oh that's great
hahaha
that was hilarious
Sasquatch walk into frame
date mode
Daddy Mode Robo baby oh he's definitely
got way more like ornate branding he's
only got 90s branding RoboCop
this is a must
oh protect the baby
everyone aim for his body
shoot everywhere but his face
man be shot he's got more personality
that was cool
why do I feel like this teenage boy is
going to be important I feel like he's a
sidekick yeah he's the Lone Wolf and Cub
storyline
yeah
hey she's back
[Music]
they're even acting differently like
they're moving I don't know it's weird
there's some things like different oh
yeah I mean it's it's lost it's great
grounded real but I was prepared for
that it's fair it's just weird that even
emotion I'm like this looks different
[Music]
kids and tons of stuff I think I can't
shoot a kid can you
whoa
oh the one smart kid the one smart guy
in the movie of anyone
oh
oh my God it's gonna be a father-son
story Lone Wolf in Cub with a kid
[Applause]
no [__] from either one of you plot
trajectory is he gonna Ricochet it off
the door
we can't have that yes smart
do we get to meet his family oh yeah
they would be alive oh very much so I
think this takes place mere months after
the first my impression was they were
dead for some reason just left him
[Music]
do you see my RoboCop movie would be a
psychological Thriller about RoboCop
cracking and wanting his family back
I've been mine about the internet he'd
have an existential crisis about whether
Humanity was worth saving or not Allah
thematic I would go
he'd become psychotic and wants to kill
whoever her his wife is now sleeping
with
it's a Revenge Thriller yeah
I want a man versus self versus machine
see it would be from her perspective all
this creepy stalker stuff oh it's like
Jaws robocops jaws you have any idea
what you're doing to that poor woman
take a look at her file hmm Mrs Murphy
is bringing suit against ocp my name is
Tom Delaney I'm representing oh this is
an interesting plot spying on her trying
to make her think her husband is still
alive she's barely started to accept the
loss oh
that is interesting do you think you
could ever be a husband to her what can
you offer her not gonna lie guys I love
this plot idea yeah this is a great name
I'm reinvesting are you Alex Murphy no
are you human you are simply a machine
oh no say No I um
oh that loss of Soul oh wow a vacant
stare hey this is a good character setup
for Murphy what is he what is his
identity what is it what is humanity for
this guy that was the movie I wanted a
minute ago no I'm getting it yeah
before Oh this is tragic Alex don't you
remember me
it's not how I expected her to behave
touch me
he wants to be human
they made this
to honor him to honor him your husband
is dead I don't know you
gotta reject it I mean it's ultimately
what is best for her we saw that
transition in him but he sacrifices his
own soul for this thought all
communication systems were the same I
tried to save the company a few bucks it
took two days to download specs from
Cleveland I lost the account
it's a hell of a
commercial
I had missed the commercials commercials
are amazing we're taking Detroit
privately you deliberately undermined
our credit that was the easy part
prick do you know how many people are
dying
that they murder us if I was you to say
nothing further it might be I
okay so they're shining more of a
spotlight this time on the dangers of
capitalism over Humanity it's that good
sequel escalation of like they got away
with it now they're this far I love how
they are keeping them as bad guys even
though RoboCop saved him in the last
movie he learned nothing
the name of the title of the movie is
the thing oh this is meta
RoboCop 2 does not look great oh my God
all right
[Music]
simple CP is proud to present the future
of urban pacification RoboCop 2.
Urban pacification [__]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it rips his own head off that was
hilarious robots with emotional problems
not robots cyborgs this proves you need
the human we use living through human
tissue and that's our whole problems
ampt big Tech nope finding themselves
stripped of all that is no wonder they
become
our one success was a cop it's an Alex
Murphy top of his class devout Irish
Catholic Family Man indicates a fierce
sense of Duty that's probably what kept
Him alive the individual I believe that
Murphy's case was unusual but not unique
we can find someone else someone to whom
the prospect might even be desirable
where can you find a cop who's a devout
Irish Catholic I don't think they make a
lot of Irish cows
don't check New Yorker bust
[Music]
what a fascinating question would you
only want to Serve and Protect if you
were getting paid to do it
yes I mean it's a job I mean yeah okay
I mean I'm just saying why would it be a
vigilante no
oh
that's him that kid would grow up to be
Bon Jovi see my RoboCop movie he would
take him kill him and then turn him into
a robochild ah to replace his own One
Cop per car okay these are the roots
three cars
one copper car that's right
did he really pay the man
[Music]
kid Kingpin
don't you should really count it you
know
give him something to help him with his
conscience
no that's right I don't really want it
come on Duffy I know you need it that's
how he keeps him
keeps him addicted don't lose me movie
you got a problem
it's a very believable someone
that's just real me in until losing
freeze turn around put your hands up I'm
gonna hold my gun up against you for a
while oh damn
walk and then say freeze
that guy was probably the stunt
coordinator
[Laughter]
oh hell no
no John Belushi don't [__] this up man
it's all on you
have a seat
where is Kane I told you I don't know
[Music]
arcade violence River Rouge the old
sludge plant
you're a rotten cop
[Music]
Ghostbusters
see I feel like the production design of
the world the sets and stuff and the
paintings yeah I feel like it's like a
seven right now and I needed to go to a
10. yep because the first one was a ten
just amp it up like I don't care if it's
neon or whatever if it looks like the
but this is doing it for you with a
sticker on the side that was peeling off
like the graffiti on the walls just amp
it up yeah
this guy's whole Situation's amazing
this outfit this bolo tie combo
don't worry Murphy's lips are still
intact
not a scratch
how did he pull that off he somehow knew
and pushed the cut I don't I don't have
answers
oh steel metal ground is not ideal for
robocops sneaking very stealthy clanks
they made this day a bit David the small
tune and Ant-Man playing that role I
think the kid's gonna have a change of
heart I hope so
I am a devout Roman Catholic
who loves rock and roll
that explains that guy's hair though oh
yeah no wait is that Elvis yes
so like the body of Elvis I wasn't
expecting Elvis like why
that are five one of us Must Die oh he
was just saying the question
do you want me dead or alive I thought
he was gonna yeah quote the tagline
[Music]
it's like a clean off
man this kid's
oh [__] they program you and you do it
all right
let me just try I forgive you God I
would love to be a cult leader it seems
simpler
thank you
smart man
this is face to one's act oh damn it's a
small bruise
I wonder if the cop it's actually kind
of sinister
I wonder if the cop like set it up like
that'd be great if the cop because it is
perfectly designed to torture a Robocop
do they want to make Robocop their own
they say he's got a brain I want to see
it you think it was me that beat you it
was this are they gonna give
it to me addicted to drugs
YouTube this drug is not real it is made
up it's called nuke
damn they're dismembering RoboCop come
on cut it out
I really do like how they're they are
keeping this menacing Vibe about what is
his identity
they just threw body parts at the cops
oh my goodness
Christ has been stripped oh that is
horrifying what a great use of the
animatronics I know every
support keeping the brain going with
micro shocks oh my God your daughter Sue
young is about to be kidnapped
this unit needs millions of dollars in
Parts you can't expect authorization for
that kind of cash outlay overnight you
don't fix him it's murder this movie is
surprising me I'm enjoying more next
especially yeah
oh no Double Cross by the criminals eh
you told them where we were oh it wasn't
clever you think you're the only cop we
have
how did they know he told them
maybe the kid heard it
I thought that woman was there like a
cat in a second it starts oh my God do
not want
him doesn't he look scared oh
watch you learn you learn little boy
[Music]
I have no use to society oh smart it's
just about the determination that is
clever and messed up they're gonna get
their own evil
anti-robo yeah Robo murderer Robo
criminal oh my God yes sequel
waiting for him
way to go man now she told her stick
that Robo criminal onto you
[Music]
bicep reboot I would not want to wake up
in this condition man
cool prosthetic thing
it's horrifying he's critical I've got
to stay with him I'll let you know when
we need your services nobody
that is really well done though that is
horrifying it really is
recommend program
like um visit an orphanage uh in the
first movie he was playing with kids and
saying stay in school uh
um officer Alex Murphy Detroit Police
Department that won't do
[Music]
RoboCop crime prevention unit I must
learn to lie I type it you think it you
type it
I think it is it working or is she
hacking him you're free you're free from
doubt free from having to make painful
choices yeah one-eyed choice at school
it's about Duality core the dichotomy
between dark and light yeah
that is an interesting question though I
must ask myself if I could just have it
inputted into my brain would I want that
rather than the distance yeah
that smile's so unnerving ready for Duty
partner you're better let's go
he sounds terrific
this is how imagine the cartoon is I'm
going to say something that I feel like
might be an unpopular opinion uh-oh I
think the script is better than the way
this movie is directed that's what I was
saying earlier I like the bones of it
more than I like how it's being executed
so far I wonder if the Irvine cursed it
I don't know if he really quite knew how
to bring totally yeah yeah
I'm able to separate the script from the
direction and I'm like the script is
pretty solid yeah I see why Weller
signed on yeah when he had it
[Music]
I love this little league gang
wake up will ya good morning
[Laughter]
hell yeah
I need to talk with you
I think we should talk
there are so many more kid criminals in
this it's amazing whether
were they still here a little bastards
come up against the wall let's go
there's something about the nihilism and
the corruption of Innocence that I love
the intention of it and I think
scripting wise if the but the directing
seems like it's holding back a bit you
know I feel like Paul verhoven should
have come back oh I would have loved
that yeah
there's a perfect step
harps
I'm having trouble
[Laughter]
that was that was really cool having
trouble think of mom and dad what kind
of lesson are you teaching them a word
on nutrition
[Applause]
the point is we all have to work
it's ocp they did something to you I'm
fine this movie is still so much better
than I was led to believe same
I thought it's gonna be like a d this is
gonna be a terrible film yeah it was not
like I was like I didn't expect any of
this seriously some of the comedy is
really well done too
oh my God there is so much beamable
stuff here yeah have I not seen memes of
this yet
[__]
thank you
thank you for not smoking
[Music]
wow pool opinions for expressing
yourself holy [__] they put all this
nonsense into his brain he has to obey
are you
are you prey as insulation
what is happening yeah what a total
shift does he know is he aware
[Music]
oh he's willing to risk it he heard how
to save himself
[Music]
there's so much more electricity in this
movie or trying to mislead us into
thinking he's unaliving himself but he's
actually trying to reboot his sister
yeah
this whole movie is like that one
episode of all those Marvel Netflix
shows of just our superhero healing
gotta go through the Walkabout man
no directives foul he's back to being
Alex Murphy we'll offer our customers
the opportunity to control every aspect
their emotional lives blue velvet I
think it's ready sir yeah see there's
some interesting topics they're touching
on like the corruption and control of
human emotion and that that controls
like consumerism there's there's so many
things that they're touching on that I
think is really interesting but they're
touching on so many and so quickly it's
really like not as thematically charged
as the first because it's like it's just
not it's not as focused yeah but it's
still attempting stuff hey cops huh what
cops
and they ain't carrying no ticket signs
they're going to kick somebody's ass
I love little moments like that in 80s
and 90s movies Side characters getting
their best guest star moments
great
[Music]
yo oh oh oh I thought his leg was blown
off okay nevermind
old school squibs all right who's gonna
kill this kid
I think he's just gonna get injured but
I don't know if he reforms he's done a
lot of murder
the cops
[Music]
love some good practicality
yeah
[Laughter]
oh my goodness oh that's a dope stun
that is a brave stunt like team that was
incredible bartender there especially
yeah
[Music]
fun sequence this is awesome oh [__] oh
the sound
Good Will of the seat oh nice take a
bite take off a bike gotta get on the
bike
yes he needs a Lucius Fox
he does he does
oh Robocop and a bike is as cool as that
hoped
wanna play chicken you wanna get nuts
can he crash into it then fly through
the window
[Music]
I love that the plot device hole gave
them a better shot like that was so
cleverly framed oh yes he did he did
did exactly what I was hoping for 500
million in cash nuke money
[Music]
's Kane who may not live the subject is
violently anti-social given to delusions
of
godhood oh he's got to be the other
RoboCop Robo criminal's gonna be the big
bad
how did we not see that even just now
when they said he was almost dead yeah
we were bad movie viewers it was right
there the whole movie it's like one of
the most predictable platforms just on
the nose
I'm through arguing with you and I'm not
asking for your permission Kane is in
the hospital that we're going to get I
didn't realize you were a little boy you
physically can be overpowered you're
you
know that's not fair
[Music]
it's not recording
you little bastard real bear ad acting
going on here when the movie's doing a
like an intentional comedy moment it's
it's funny it's good but this movie has
a lot of what just registers as
unintentionally funny yeah like this
scene out of context is hilarious why
did we just cut out that two minutes
you're gonna have a chance for
immortality as long as nothing happens
to that lovely brain he's becoming the
exact thing he did not want to become
I'm afraid we lost our patient yep he
just expired right
whoa that is so cold
hold your breath
let's see the brain
show time we had it here it comes I
don't know about the rest of you I'm
hungry
[Music]
of what it looks like Mars Attacks
so gross
it's a turn in my stomach a bit
yeah yeah
I love that the POV of Robocop to this
POV of like evil and just seeing his own
removed face if you want honest
government
to dig deep into your pockets
where does that put us Gilly
hello this is your honor
very good news for you the surprise look
good they do someone's showing up to
bail the city out your services to ocp
will be rewarded we shifted 80 of our
liquid resources to the urban
pacification plant and ocp will plummet
so will our stock I love the idea of the
urban pacification as a way to feign uh
safety and privatized city is terrifying
as an idea yeah
if you want to you're not bringing
up bringing my lab I will do worse than
get you fired now leave me alone God you
know man I really just feel like it
needed a better director and I like
Empire a lot like there's just a lack of
fervor behind the camera itself like
it's kind of shot like a TV movie and
it's really buggy like a really well
done TV movie but you're not talking to
screaming well like back in the day TV
movies like this is him as a disembodied
CGI monster like that doesn't that
doesn't work why not just keep his face
almost every frame just sort of feels
like a TV movie to me and it's I
wouldn't if any of you could help me I'm
looking for a Mr Hopper how much you
need money I mean
37 million four hundred and eighty
thousand nine hundred and eleven dollars
guess you're in some pretty deep [__]
well you need all the help we can get
young man he's
he's [__] let's get out of here
[Music]
oh they're smart and they can control
privatizing the city for them
[Music]
gentlemen
well will 50 do it terrible 80r
[Laughter]
remotely close to being in sync
there's been a Robocop for a while oh
yeah that's a good point
conscious or no we got Raptor claws for
some reason why why drugs people do
drugs because they want drugs nuke gives
high quality at a cheap price we don't
go shoving our [__] down anybody's
throat and we don't advertise it like
they do with cigarettes or booze All
Things Considered little kid is not bad
he's not it's the way others act around
him it's always going to be a little
cheesy just because of context but he's
not bad it's not him yeah
oh no the little boy's gonna get injured
Raptor evil RoboCop
oh no the mayor mayor's dead
[Music]
why would you even try to shoot this
thing okay maybe maybe why would you try
to shoot you know you can't shoot
RoboCop why would you treasure
[Music]
I guess one of the checklists of a
Robocop movie is shootouts in
manufacturing warehouse locations
we got this set we gotta use it
man this guy's been a tough guy probably
till he wasn't
Scorpion King face
he's just become there it is oh no
uh
[Music]
okay actor's doing the work I'm just
gonna give her credit
make love to it cold iron hand
it'll be great
[Music]
[__]
oh man oh man
he's so mean to her
whoa
where'd he go where has he been a small
truck
why don't you just pretend to be dead
[Music]
Detroit
symbolism
what it's very subtle
innocence corrupted by greed
nine-year-old Wall Street boy surrounded
by money that couldn't save him I will
call for a medical emergency unit
who did this it was Kane I'm gonna die
you know what that's like don't you it
really sucks yeah you don't know what he
went through
a few times
I think the most emotionally compelling
part of this movie was introduced so
early on about his wife and [__] and
then I just I hate that they just
completely annihilated it's like the
20-minute section plot points that could
be entire race yeah
sorry folks video
[Music]
what's this Nazi rally it's not a Nazi
rally what a black leather are they
trying to make it look like ah okay good
there is no hint it's been subtle
throughout
telling you it's not what you think guys
magnificent structure
corporations human experimentation I
don't see any Nazis authoritarianism
privatizing entire city no degree
we're going to build a brand new city
for Detroit now status
an example to the world
I love movies about evil corporations
that are produced by evil corporations
that's why I love the boys on Amazon so
makes the most profit the people who
produce the movie they know what they're
doing you'll have to tear down a lot of
people's houses before you can make that
thing and take away their homes every
citizen will have a living unit nobody
elected you anyone can buy ocp stock and
own a piece of our city this is how we
got to trumpism
come on 51 of our audiences man we need
a law enforcement unit capable of
meeting the enemy on his own ground to
get the job done
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen towering over the
city a monolith
RoboCop 2
made in America mean something again
how did he sneak it a hand Cannon and a
Robocop
a hundred of these are produced every
day RoboCop 2
will seek out every laboratory every
dealer and rid our city of Newton you
know there's an addict in there let's
see how this goes
it wasn't just an attitude it was the
head distributor
what's wrong with him it's nothing at
all I turned him off I can't Jane let's
step outside
[Music]
killer
not even
[Music]
that controller is huge arms
this guy needs to stop creating cyborgs
learn come on guys going wrong it
doesn't work out
oh
[Music]
yeah
the old Super Punch
[Music]
cool Neko design
you should
smarts man yeah
[Music]
whoa that's a cool shot that's actually
kind of scary
that was sad
yes
90s you need your climax to be where our
hero might fall to his death mirroring
the long-armed guy falling in the first
one you're coming with me okay
the hero's sacrifice
[Music]
oh whoa guys I can promise you that
wasn't a green screen was not no
blackout lines
oh it's Duality and duplicitousness you
see this it's a humanoid versus the
inhuman monstrosity of man a lot about
this movie has made me sad
okay I'm not gonna lie
there's a lot of things that just left
me feeling like empty yeah there's a lot
I was really enjoyed about it but as
it's gone on it's it's Highs are high
but it's lows are low yeah
yeah
definitely a sequel
ouch
[Music]
Robot Chickens RoboCop too
guys everyone needs to evacuate the city
of Detroit
perhaps leave Detroit
[Music]
that must have been a cool toy battle
ravaged RoboCop I feel like they wanted
to sell toys this time yeah I mean look
at that that's a toy
[Music]
this plant has gotten so awry
why even attempt
there you go clear the civilians
if you don't have like a a bazooka
this could look bad for ocp jobs
[Music]
is he gonna OD the robot for a movie
that thematically sets up the question
of soul and Humanity this movie manages
to lose its Soul as it goes and like the
opening and end are so soulless like the
bookends are so like well this is what I
was afraid yeah it's really sad it's
kind of cool looking I suppose it's got
lots of moments
see that was a cool shot
the license plates are barcodes yeah I
like that
[Music]
wow Detroit is full of idiots
foreign
[Music]
the cops and Nazis have to work together
that's not until 2023.
[Music]
why did RoboCop go up that escalator a
thing to get the drugs okay
Association I didn't connect the dots
for a bit and I was like what's where is
he going I think that's why
[Music]
I thought that would do it I mean it
wouldn't take out RoboCop but I thought
it was maybe if I just drive this tank
into this guy yeah bullets won't do it
let's give him what he wants
[Music]
Target to memory that's clever
it's the Kardashian Coca-Cola ad
meth vocab
[Music]
I like how the scientist lady's still
hoping her robot will win yeah
I thought she might say behind you or
something
[Music]
plot is fine like Predator Judge Dread
movie ripped a lot of this off oh my God
oh my God the whole brain and everything
goodbye
[Music]
thank you
sweet
[Music]
oh yeah stretch your back out
it's good
unless RoboCop is three is so bad it's
good I have no interest in watching I
agree this hurt me a little bit yeah
I've gotten so excited such a roller
coaster with this particular one it's
gone from like a minus to D minus and
back yeah
this becomes like a void
don't be hard on yourself everything's
going to be all right
we're talking about
get right on it this is like a great
example of it being so on the nose and
heavy-handed and holding on too long
like that was not all her showing up and
uh just yeah it's like it doesn't get
the direction and script need to work
together and like directors work with
their writers on rewriting and stuff and
I really think that and I also feel like
there's corporate input on this one
we need toys
it just becomes like flat
over that body
will ocp make reparations to the victims
it's just a problem for me when a movie
goes bigger but there's less energy yeah
you know
patience Lewis
we're only human
[Music]
I guess they didn't bring the wife back
for the third Act
screenplay by Frank Miller Story by
Frank Miller so the story I did like and
written by Walton yeah whatever two
written Buys in one story by so maybe
maybe Frank Miller and and uh yeah my
guess would be
that Frank Miller wrote this
and then
it brought in another guy to change it
up rewrite the work of Frank Miller and
I feel like Frank Miller and verhoven
could have made a hell of a Robocop too
yeah yeah alrighty guys well hey uh now
that we're in the review portion I want
to say that if you're here
um I've been watching appreciate it but
we're also on like apple and Spotify and
so if you're listening to this on the
podcast formula real rejects please
though what do you do on podcasts you
like that I like it you can leave a
review rate it rate it all do it all and
also while we're here I want to say
thank you to all I've been buying some a
real rejects apparel I'm wearing right
right now I think an appropriate thing
to wear for a thing about
you know corporations and consumerism is
who influences the influencers with my
little boy Rorschach right now but we
also got a whole bunch of other teas
that is an amazing way to support the
channel
and yeah yeah so thank you all for
listening
hoy alrighty
well
if you watch the reaction I think you'll
see that we were rarely open my okay we
had a journey
basic journey of my emotional Journey
with this
started off cheesy and I went all right
it's cheesy I see the problems but I
feel like it's gonna be a fun time then
I was going oh wait
this movie's actually a lot smarter than
I expected there's actually some depth
to this they're making some interesting
choices in commentary and emotional
decisions
then it started a bob and weave it's
wrapping it all up adding new stuff
sprinkling speeding yeah and then by the
time we got to which you can only
describe as like a Marvel for now where
uh or a comic book movie finale which is
kind of appropriate for a comic book
writer to have done this
um it the lasting impression that it
left me with was wow this movie has lost
its soul and I'm not sure exactly what
point it was but it it reached some
point where I realized
when was it when can I pinpoint one I
think it was when we had lost Robin
Wright order was this known if that's
Robin right
um there's a good chunk when we didn't
have RoboCop right I was gonna say I
think when we lost RoboCop I realized
they weren't gonna wrap it up in a way
that was gonna feel fulfilling and then
once RoboCop came back it was just
action RoboCop return it was just the
first half the First Act and the the
second half the third act were soulless
and the middle was solid but I do think
that second half the third Act was like
okay I mean the First Act was at least
a little fun yeah but I think it was
just being back in robocopic but this
movie didn't I to me and maybe you guys
love the the finale and had fun with it
I personally did not I thought that it
was it started to become really I just
felt numb and it was long if yeah this
movie felt [__] long like whenever
whenever they'd hold on all the action I
was like okay it dragged it started to
drag which is insane because there are
so many 20-minute sections that
introduce really interesting themes and
Concepts and they'd rush through those
and then the action would be really long
and heavy-handed and then they'd like
undermine some of the ideas they'd set
up and rush to the next thing but then
it still felt long it was weird they
didn't it wasn't even that the execution
itself was getting rushed it was the
wrap up to it that was yeah it was it
would set you up like oh we're gonna
spend some time here oh it's over yeah
that's where it kept sort of going these
in these strange increments
um okay like I loved this setup with him
and his wife which is not come around I
really thought third act would bring her
back and it didn't because he
essentially goes on the same character
Arc yeah that he went on in the first
one which is rediscovering I am human
you know it's the same it's the same
character art it didn't do anything
different and I thought they could have
explored his place of identity here and
how much of him was human how much he
still felt like himself because I
thought that was the setup at the end of
the first movie is like he's found who
he is but now he needs to accept him as
Robocop and that's what I thought the
second movie was gonna be yeah and it
seemed like that's what they were
setting up here and then they didn't and
they they just did not go through with
that
um like the scene with him and his wife
I thought was an extremely compelling
scene um
and and then the the the world I think
the world of
um nuke
and it's not fair to compare it but it
is the only thing I got on my on my mind
right now I think the world of nuke
needed the touch of a movie that came
out decades later dread which red did
with slow-mo of this is really
controlling the the world this is how
the criminals Dominate and they kind of
did like talking about it but I didn't
feel the world this time it was just
Exposition with another that was a big
missing ingredient for me was and I was
trying to touch on that and figure it
out as the movie went
the first one I felt the world I didn't
feel like this was lived in
um it seemed very surface and trying to
be this is exactly 1990 wow so yeah we
said transition for 80s and 90s they
filmed this in 89 it came out in 90.
okay so it's exactly that wow
um yeah so uh but when they started like
tear him open
and and strip him down to pieces I was
like wow what a compelling concept
because and you they set it up it's not
just I don't think it's us just being
this is the movie I I didn't know
there's not no version of this movie
that I wish it would be something yeah
we thought of 10 different things that
we would have gone with that plot Point
yeah and then we'd go like okay we're
here now let's go this way with what
what could be and then it kept just
abandoning the interesting one yeah
because you got the the cops on strike
yep
um which is an interesting world to set
up of how the the uh what was it called
Omni core Omni takeover on privatize the
city yes they're controlling it they're
paying to keep the cops on strike like
that was smart smart Ingenuity and a
great
a great follow-up from the first one
since the cops and the first one were
saying we should go on strike and yeah
we set it up they're going like okay
perfect great sequel setup and then
RoboCop the one hope for law enforcement
is now torn apart and that mistake so
you can fight a human like we display it
on the cops who are fighting for their
rights yeah you know like oh this is
hopeless for them we had five minutes
with that they were like yeah and then
he's back did they reprogram him and oh
they've they've took complete control
over him and made him not at all what he
is designed to be
and that's like half an act like that
was like 15 minutes it's like maybe 15
minutes and it's funny but interesting
and oh this is very very different and
what and as they're building some other
Sinister machine
and then they just can it yeah it really
it's a really it really starts to bum
you out and the commentary on like
controlling drugs and the the world that
Frank Miller does so well which
definitely it's funny when I watch
Robocop one I kept thinking like man I
bet Frank Miller loved this I think we
even talked about it yeah and then this
one being written Frank Miller found
feels a lot like his Dark Knight Returns
with you know the the bad guys running
the town and even the shadowy figure
talking like all that stuff is very
Frank Miller but they don't let you live
in the world enough with that I think
the idea was that opening would show you
like this lady beats up an old lady this
goes over here these girls take this and
like that's not enough like so it never
felt like there was actually Stakes with
the world that then they have to refer
back to yes
oh yeah man like and kidpin like he
worked sometimes and wasn't the actor oh
I wish I looked I forgot to look at the
kids actor's name I'm wondering if he
did anything else but like the kid pin
worked but it was just hard to see the
actors acting around it because
sometimes it like plausible deniability
went away sometimes suspensional
disbelief it went away also the mayor
was like sometimes in a totally
different movie with how big his
performance was and his performance was
like this big big eccentric thing that
almost felt like the satire that
verhoven does so well but then the kid
was so like in this grounded Zone it was
just really tricky I don't think Irvin
kirschner and me and maybe some of this
has something to do with the writing
itself I don't think the handle of
because the first movie had such a great
balance of satire without becoming spoof
or parody Or feeling corny or goofy like
it knew how to be it like the first
one's like Practically Perfect
um with knowing how to be all these
elements and then also take it seriously
and then find it intense and be
emotionally gripped and I was I can't
say I was ever
once emotionally gripped by anything
that happened in this movie the the one
part where I thought I might be was the
thing with the with the wife and but
then after I was never great
I'd go into modes where I was very
interested or I thought like oh this is
thought provoking or I'm appreciative of
what their talking about right now and
there's some cool set pieces I like the
I really actually like the one where
RoboCop is on the truck yeah that was
really well done and the set piece where
he's like dismembered and they're
walking him through the police station I
was the closest I was to emotionally
invested I was like where because I care
about RoboCop and Peter Weller does such
a good job him disassembled I was like
totally invested oh yeah
that was where I was like oh and then
like that was the thing I think they
abandoned quickest and then I was like
briefly very invested in the idea of
like controlling the drug narrative and
like fueling a city by making it like
we're gonna have we're gonna be 100 of
this and the mayor being like Oh I guess
that kind of works that was a
fascinating plot point and then they
abandoned that immediately the kid died
like three minutes later yeah but
there's so many moments that were almost
almost
yeah this is like this is very much the
the potential movie yeah yeah this is
one of the biggest examples of a sequel
going right and wrong simultaneously
that I've seen in a long time like when
people used to talk about sequels never
working this is a great example of like
oh so close I genuinely mean it I think
Peter Weller is Sensational he really
helps Elevate this movie yeah the
performance he gives is RoboCop I think
is people talk about you know that term
criminally underrated and I think Peter
well honestly I I feel like him as a
performer as Alex Murphy yeah is a very
very underrated because it's a role
that's easy to write off as you just got
to pretend it's like when people
like I'll give it to you if you talk
about like and I don't agree with it
I'll give it to you if you talk about
like Arnold Schwarzenegger it's like a
Terminator right it's a very specific
kind of performance here
Peter Weller knows how to bring death to
this character and the and the struggle
with uh the the emotional development of
Man vs machine all happening internally
I think it's excellent and I feel like
anytime he's on screen it's because of
Peter Weller knowing how to
that it's it's the same thing of what
Carl Urban had to learn how to do and
not the same thing but but similar where
you're not going to see this guy's eyes
or or when he's climbing like he's
literally got like less than Cyclops
face he's got nothing in like a lot of
communication is body language and tone
and he found a way to do that with this
one and and uh at the last one and the
comedy and just changing how he presents
his mouth when they when they
reprogrammed him was genius like that
was such impressive acting because
obviously it was played for laughs but
even when he wasn't speaking his mouth
was being carried in a different way in
his body language like that's incredible
and I was also really impressed that
there's only one flashback I think a
lesser film would have had way more
flashbacks to him pre-robocop you see
him as him once right right and I think
the I I like the I like how they they
put the pedal to the metal here on the
the capitalism side of things yes and
and carrying over our people from the
last movie uh which something 80s and
90s did great I always that's one of my
favorite things about the Lethal Weapon
movies is that each of the Lethal Weapon
movies has the same group of cops so
when like you lose them in the third one
you're really invested in like you've
lived with those cops it's not just the
leads it's like the whole family yeah
and I think that 80s and 90s movies did
a lot better job making uh a series feel
coherent and this felt like that where
like we see the same cops come back
we're invested in those characters too
well the the corporation people too I
think bringing them back and watch I I
like the idea that's what I mean like I
don't feel like this movie was void of
ideas because it wasn't too many ideas
yeah I think so because nothing really
gotta meet its potential its full
potential enough nothing here gotta meet
its full potential
um and I did not come into this movie
one and I hate it I actually I came and
just thought it might be fun like I
thought it might be a fun bad move I
thought it was gonna be more like the
first dread where it's like this is fun
because it's like well this is whatever
it is and then when it got good I was
actually more bummed when it regressed
yeah like if this had stayed I didn't
expect any good yeah like if that's it
this is state of C I'd be like well I
heard it's like a d or enough so I'm
happy but when this like touched that a
minus point and then dropped to a d
That's way more of like a come on like
I'm tired yeah no no that that bummed me
it bummed me out by the time we got
there um and then the last 20 minutes 17
or so minutes when it's just like all
right it's an action movie I'm like but
your RoboCop isn't like that was my when
we watched the first one we both kept
saying like I can't believe this isn't
just an action book no it felt like it
became perfunctory with it because I
thought there was an again like oh
interesting this guy who the cult leader
dude what's his name oh it's a cane Lake
I think like okay did you say something
about Han Solo I think it's like a Cain
and Abel thing I'm guessing some oh it's
because you uh uh Arnold oh arnim Zola
yeah
that's why you said that's what I was
thinking of that yeah oh but he
definitely had that Vibe which is also a
very Frank Miller That's kaneki okay
yeah when he
cause he's the one who dismembers or
instructs the dismemberment of Robocop
which I love the body horror again to
that moment and he um he's the one you
know preaching about the the
philosophical understandings of what
they've done to this guy yeah you know
so I loved him turning into this monster
he didn't see it so clearly telegraphed
was so great I think I think him turning
into that like oh that Sinister to do
and like haha you know it it can work on
a multi-layer yeah and I even like the
goofiness of like his brain in his eyes
yeah like I thought that was fun
um but it's just nothing he's just
nothing he's just a it's it actually I
think is it makes him less threatening
when it's just it like at 209
is more imposing yeah even though this
thing is like a super Advanced hyper
thing
um and and they're telling us there's a
there's a brain in this one yeah I I
felt it was more of an empty vessel
Scorpion King face didn't help
oh that was something else man it's like
lawnmower man yeah that was that was bad
hello so much work but a lot more yeah
yeah I think this is like a c for me the
last the last I want to say like 40
minutes really started to turn me off
yeah it was it it was very there's solid
hour here that I really enjoy this was
like almost almost two hours and there's
a solid hour here
or close to an hour
I really don't really have much issue
with the first like I was like yeah I
mean comparatively there's stuff I'm big
as a big of a fan of but yeah there was
like a like maybe like 45 minutes I I
really really really enjoyed some stuff
I I kind of loved
um the music was good and solid there
was sometimes it was really tonally
inappropriate that like sometimes the
the beautiful score of Robocop was used
in a way that like felt like a satire
that wasn't meant to be there were a
couple times he was like doing something
I was like this is heroic you know I
okay I heard it's funny I I've I heard
Irvin kirschner was not like really the
director of Empires I've heard that too
but I don't remember who I've heard that
like George Lucas actually was or who
actually I like George Lucas would like
kind of step back yeah or was the Return
of the Jedi I might have been both
um
and I heard Irvin kirschner
this was the last movie he directed and
he's only done TV since wow which is
fitting to me because it's felt shot
third TV it felt flat in the world
oh just the lighting and the framing
there there was no real distinct Voice
or style it it it it really felt like
made for TV in the way it would like
made for TV on a bigger budget yeah you
know and serviceable there was nothing
really cool about the way it was shot
like that was something that surprised
me about the first one was oh wow
there's a there's a there's a really
great framing yeah there's a lot of
language in the first one it's just
imagery which I loved that first movie
is so exceptional I I really can't get
over how good that first movie was but
the the pace to this I don't like I
don't like the pacing
um especially in the last 40 minutes the
the energy I feel like is void there's
no fervor to the direction here uh I I
gotta say like I think a lot actually
fell on the way this movie was directed
and I have to look up
right now
if there was something that went wrong
yeah I was so curious I'm gonna read the
Reddit immediately and get on like
Wikipedia is there behind the scenes
drama I really want to look it up koi do
you mind let's do it I'm very curious
too because like halfway through I was
like what a hodgepodge of things what
this [__] happened to here also the
relationship with uh his partner just
was uh didn't care another vessel what
went wrong with the RoboCop 2.
um I okay what did Joe Blow say all
right other than oh Jesus is such a
small pond hold on a second guys we will
get you that
we will get you
uh
again see they're they're blaming the
screen but that's part of why you
disagree that's part of where you get
and like I feel like half baked
unfinished ideas there were things that
needed more fleshing out I I agreed
because there were so many interesting
things like the script is by no means
perfect and definitely needed another
pass but I'm like I don't feel like this
that's the shitty thing about being a
writer wow look at the difference in box
office today versus then highest
grossing movie on 14.1 million during
its opening weekend that's insane how
different box office expectations are
and the tickets were like three dollars
okay hold on a sec what were the behind
the scenes problems
with a robocopter I'm just gonna get
very specific here let me see if I can
find something yeah I'm really curious
like what developed over time and how
much has been revealed because like I
feel like this is a lot of inside
baseball but now that we've entered that
four decades mark
okay
so he declined to return for the secret
um okay kirschner's vision for the film
was at all which we talked about I felt
like the entire thing was at odds
uh the producers so again exactly
exactly exactly what we said during the
reaction was that it felt there was
corporate input yes more action so they
wanted it to make it a more
action-oriented film the producers and
less satirical film than the original
and we were just saying how they did not
know how to capture the satire which is
what makes the first movie so special
okay the rush production looks like Rush
schedule okay uh I just gave the
production very little time to work you
feel that
Peter Weller wasn't happy with the
script in film's Direction he clashed
with kirschner on set again called it
the direction I could understand the
script but the part of a director's job
when selling the vision is to work with
your writers on it yeah you know I'm
saying the script's not perfect but that
is that is an integral piece
um okay it was a success or uh unhappy
star poor special effects okay so I
didn't know if it was just poor because
it was it was uh realized as that see I
can't see this as it can't be classic no
it's not quite to in either direction
yeah because it did it did not reach the
it never quite reached the point of so
like there was a a moment here or there
that was Ah that's so cheesy it's yeah
it's fun but the ca some people view it
as it can't be classic and to me I'm
like nah this just became it took itself
too serious yeah
satire was needed yeah I know man that
was that that 102 million worldwide
that's a crazy different bar everything
we suspected it would literally spelled
out it was like okay yeah those things
totally happened yeah it's it's on
screen that's so interesting you can
feel it from the vibe but yeah movies
aren't emotional going experience No
Matter What observations one might have
it's all it always comes down to what
are you feeling in your heart and the
emotion it conveyed was all the things I
suspected went wrong with this yeah this
is people bearing their souls that's
what art is and this definitely felt
like it was a hundred people with
different perspectives going like and
the irony of of a movie that starts out
thematically about the question of what
is a soul to them become such a soulless
experience too many corporate interests
might override the humanity of a
situation making it more difficult like
the movie did is that's the strangest
part about it you know is that's what
the movie's trying to talk about and
then you got the producer something and
be like you can't do that take that
apart take it rebuild it make it less
and obviously call that RoboCop 2 in the
movie was clever but now in our life
RoboCop 2 being the thing they built and
then and I can imagine for Peter Weller
it's is conflicting like when you're the
director you got to orchestrate this
sure kind of thing and then you got
you got to conduct the set but then you
got like the producers and the studio
people above you who are giving you
orders and you gotta paying for it and
you got to conduct yeah and then and
then of course you're gonna clash with
your actor yeah of course you're going
to do that because you're like you can't
satisfy both yeah especially if you're
changing the tone on the sequel that he
clearly loved in the first yeah I feel
like Irvin kirschner wanted to probably
make a better film than this yeah yeah
and like a better action movie and I
think Peter Weller probably would make a
sad talk because there's a lot of that
in the script
oh man well that was an interesting
Journey y'all uh glad to have seen it
though overall very glad to have you
ever watched yeah I really enjoyed it
like that was a good journey I'm like
not gonna watch it again but I'm glad to
have like gone through that experience
RoboCop one I will I will watch it
unless RoboCop three is like okay this
is so bad that it's enjoyable I mean I
honestly feel like we just go to the
reboot if we're making that decision
because if we're gonna go so bad it's
bad instead of reboots not that bad I
like what's his name kinnamon I heard
it's like very serious yeah but because
I mean that first one's so special
I think I've seen it I just don't
remember that is not a good sign that
it's not that bad hey man
there's a Whole Decade Greg just missed
I have I have that memory problem yeah I
mean it's good for us because
positive but I can't tell you anything
that specifically goes down in that
there's a lot of 80s and 70s I missed
and Greg missed the 2000s by way of
being a little toasty yeah I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty confident I saw it at
least once yeah I'm very intrigued well
let us know in the comments what you
want us to dive into next I'd rather
enjoy these 80s action movie adventures
with Greg but uh we are now we just did
a 1991 but this whole tone I'm really
about so let us know in the comments
anything you want us to check out please
do like share subscribe hit that
notification all the things and we will
see you very soon much love rejection
whoa
oh we should have someone out shout
something out Michael Linden I'm gonna
look up real fast this guy's from Sweden
he's from Sweden okay and uh I feel like
Sweden is in need of a Robocop so
Mikhail here's what we gotta do we've
got to get you killed first oh and and
then we have to turn your body into that
of a cybernetic
I'm trying to type a whole different
question
what is the crime rate in Sweden and
then uh we gotta turn you my friend into
a cybernetic organism design only for
saving only for savings
and then because right now let's see
here
um in 2022 in uh out of a hundred
thousand uh inhabitants
the crime rate was out of only 15
000 most of that being uh theft drug
related offenses and robbery lack of
murder though so I mean they got health
insurance this side rate is low we die
easier here because we got a lot of
things where you can't save most crime
rates are non-violent and that would be
the Dilemma for your people of Sweden
just assess assess RoboCop people will
be like we don't need this RoboCop
Stockholm it's higher so we'd go there
but then still be like bro it's just
like a petty drug charge what are you
doing RoboCop we don't need you to be
shooting us can't imagine he's cheap to
run it would not be cheap it would
probably run the Country Dry I mean I
imagine it's like nuclear or something I
think we would probably make Bank
corruption with the economy would be in
complete disarray just shambles because
that's a very small population in
general your fault and people would
blame you you would not be making Sweden
better no no you'd be the bad guy in
RoboCop in fact this was all horrible
idea and I don't know why you agree to
it you did poor writing versus Studio
interference is what happened as per
RoboCop too and in this case we're both
but we appreciate you being a patron
well we Sully your country with our bad
idea that's the American way that's what
we do we're gonna invade we're gonna
colonize we're gonna make bad ideas
we're gonna pretend it wasn't us we're
gonna get out of there yeah Sweden
Sweden
foreign
[Music]